piano thierry ardisson quand on connaît
pas que j'aie jamais rencontré vraiment
dont parfois on parle parfois et
j'espère que celui que je connais va
complètement
voilà diack un thierry ardisson ce
n'était pas la télé je pourrais te dois
de draguer marié tu sais moi je suis
sérieuse alors ce n'était pas la télé on
parlerait de ton actu tu crois non on
n'en parlerait pas en fait ce n'était
pas ça n'était pas été on ne parle pas
des noms mais en parler parce qu'on a
maintenant tout ce que tu t'intéresses à
tout ce que je fais dans tu me donnes
aimerait leur nom j'aimerais bien sûr en
arrivant je pense que je te demanderai
de trois questions
on me donnait une comptes d'accor je
crois que alex qu'il croit que les mecs
ils ont décidé ouais j'avais dit aux
deux questions est-ce que ça va
intéresser le public mon spectacle
ouais tu vas voir qu'après cette
émission décor il va intéresser le plus
et jamel
c'est michel tu vois tu veux
non mais non nettoie fait comme si de
rien n'était mais vous continuez vos
émissions alesi a les idées noires
on y va on a un problème il n'a pas un
caméra oui 4 je pense que ma veste et
qu'il n'a pas fait nous partons sur les
rendent bien
il revient à tannique et l'oeil des
freestyles c'est le mec de blanc dit tu
sais où je suis désolé s'est quittés
potes qui sont avec toi là ddd est
repris de justice sociale
[Applaudissements]
je continue
alors messieurs tu m'as michel tu vas tu
es dans [ __ ] dure donc avec d'armor
dutronc dany boon a exactement mais je
crois qu'on va beaucoup s'amuser et dany
boon tu l'as tu l'as vu sept ans sinon
la dernière fois que je les ai vus j'ai
pas vu sa pièce mais je vais y aller
parce qu'il était en vacances à megève
il ay les voilà il avait l'air enfants
et j'ai remis de sa séparation d'avec
judith parce qu'elle était la semaine
dernière bell a l'air de s'être bien
remise et je commençais à séparation lui
aussi ce maestro la lame avant
catherine une métairie à madjer c'est
dans sa vie car il me demande si on peut
aller chercher une baisse de secours
chez moi catherine
mais si je donne le code comme je fais
une autre émission chez moi tu donnes
code catherine c'est mort c'est dommage
que philippe de gaulle soit partie
hommage à la dame en noir et qui fait
faire philippe de gaulle nous soit
quelques heures
c'est sûr bien donc
judith godrèche et hélas la semaine
dernière ils avaient l'air d'avoir assez
bien appris sa séparation d'avec dany
boon ça allait nous et tant mieux oui
dany ça va aussi
j'ai l'impression en passant faire pour
eux non alors il ya aussi un coffret qui
va sortir avec ils s'aiment ils se
sentent ils y voient là avec pierre il
se fait engueuler non mais ça va les
cameramen avec caméra djamel oui combien
les frais qui sort alors des kits somme
ils se sont eux-mêmes mais là c'est ça
la saga complète tu penses tu fais quoi
michel quand tu pars tout le temps à los
angeles comme ça alors moi je prépare un
film j'ai acheté les droits d'un livre
qui s'appelle pitch de caroline bon
groupe je le connais voilà c'est bien
sûr et on voudrait faire un film inspiré
de ce livre tu vas faire un film sauvez
le pic
peut-être alors tu vas venir le pitch
est ici un max obligatoire et alors je
n'étais pas la télé ce que je pourrais
couper les moments où j'ai l'air
concours je te regarde jamais l'air con
c'est vrai oui c'est une idée que tu te
fais tu impressionné ce n'était pas la
télé tu dirais quoi du décor de cette
émission
franchement il ya un truc que j'aime
beaucoup c'est la veste mais vraiment
vous cacher ça sert je trouve que c'est
sept ans
un petit truc ce changement car tout
petit truc je vais la signer way up
ouais
[Applaudissements]
là
valérie peut venir là valérie sa part
comment sur la peau axa pas vraiment
ouais je crois que là je suis comme ça
pour un long moment
est ce qu'on peut faire valérie un des
lingettes loges est là revient avec des
lingettes valérie je continue interview
de madame laroque
je termine ici alors ce n'était pas la
télé tu aurais quoi comme problème à me
raconter je sais pas ce qu'il ya eu dans
le ciel les armes et caetera que les
gens qui étaient un peu fragiles sont
allées très très très mal ouais j'avais
plein de coups de fil de gens qui
allaient mal et ça m'a vraiment inquiété
voilà c'est ça le problème en fait
nettement baisser les gens flippe un peu
en ce moment c'est la période de l'année
bachy nancy n'est pas comme si peu
satisfaisant ouais ouais
et puis comme je suis maintenant entre
les deux c'est quand je reviens je sens
plus ces choses parce que j'ai pas su
bien tu vois toutes les pressions ici et
je trouve que parfois c'est très lourd
et si je trouve que les gens sont plus
flipper enfin aux états unis en france
soit c'est différent ils sont très fines
inférieures avec vous je ne peux pas les
causes de bouche mais sinon mais les
gens n'ont plus le moral gagner quelque
chose ou est de 12 je trouve un truc à
nous et les gens ont pu la pêche non
qu'est ce qui se passe là bas
yassir pas catherine gillet dans la loge
vip d'accord ok je viens d'assister les
choses extraordinaires ici j'espère que
ta famille un costume non non c'est
louis b n'écoute pas et c'est par amour
un jouet thierry
ri té un chic type pensée pour moi
hassan ier
[Applaudissements]
il c'est en fini il s'est enfui à le
janet
tiens si quelqu'un pouvait maîtriser
jamel debbouze
personne n'a agi de questions à poser à
thierry thierry tu m'entends je
t'entends djamel comment tu peux mettre
des photos pareil sérieux quoi qui axe
mais david mali della quoi rien mauvaise
mise sur cette photo mais c'est le style
de la photo djamel troll aulas le centre
adhap rendra à dire que mon spectacle
n'est pas intéressante bouffon vert
alors même si on n'était pas la
télévision
même s'ils n'étaient pas la télévision
est ce que tu me parlerait quand même de
gerpinnes teurs à bastia ouais c'est
bien c'est bien celui-ci l'avait bien
content pour lui parce que c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de
talent et j'adore le spectacle fait les
gens mais ce martèlement et voilà quoi
c'est sait quelque chose
il a été longtemps à toulouse il est
arrivé à paris là tout seul on lui a pas
encore la pression et s'excuser sous la
pression qui nous a donné exactement et
il y croit vraiment et je trouve que
c'est bien et alors il est venu ici nous
parler de son nouveau spectacle qui
s'appelle on tire bien sûr les lapins au
théâtre fontaine tu l'as vu évidemment
rien ça fait marrer oui ces matches il
adore et ma mère elle adore tu vois
c'est un tout génération doit bientôt
mais en fait super bien à temps qu'est
ce qui se passe maintenant sérieusement
écoute moi on va lui ont valu à mener
une vaste gamme 4 et il laisse pas faire
un docteur kiffer quatre prix dont on
est avec toi
attendez pris un temps de deux minutes
quand on voit dans tout new york mexico
public atteint 5 défis jeunes
voilà je compte des filles je te pince
ainsi j'arrête je te parle pas assez
sévères
[Musique]
bien et ben voilà dont catherine barma
catherine barma elle aussi patente jamel
debbouze
[Applaudissements]
l'habitat
bonsoir
ce soir
je vois je vois vraiment ces moustiques
je vois que tu es tombé sur le sur le
même plan
je viens de te soutenir on s'était un
peu au sol ça te va très bien oui toi
aussi 1 1
je te regarder à l'écran c'est bon c'est
bien mais à un moment donné c'est
pénible mais servent au début de
l'émission ça va mais quand il va être
hui voilà le matin surtout pas exact
c'est que j'ai vu des trucs
extraordinaires dont je vous raconte pas
ce qu'on les prenne pas vu j'ai vu
monsieur de gaulle donc l'amiral de
gaulle croisé gabriel cohn bendit à oka
brial cohn bendit lui a dit bonjour
gabriel cohn bendit il a tiqué le vieux
disque est drôle c'est que c'est des
rencontres par procuration ouais c'est
assez lent vivre herbe cohn bendit avec
le fils de de gaulle oui voilà c'est ça
qui est marrant et lui la tique est
enfin en fait donc son fish
non il a marqué le coup c'est rigolo
alors qu'il sait que maria pacôme est
venu au théâtre pendant la guerre son
père était déporté à buchenwald et
qu'elle allait au cours simon enfin
plutôt à côté du court ciment dans un
district s'appelle le villars et alors
si mentalement c'est mieux en face
d'accord et simon lui a dit cette phrase
mémorable tu n'es pas une beauté
mais entre garde ce qui veut dire que
tout de suite il avait vu que vous aviez
une présence avec moi un peu pour me
flageller qui rajoute et n'est pas une
beauté voilà ce malgré ça peut quand
même être un peu excessif
il a dit ouais mais tu as une présence
le jour
mais souvent je compare michèle laroque
à elvire popesco parce qu'elles sont
roumaine toutes les deux mais je crois
que j'aurais pu aussi vous comparez à
maria pacôme au cannet michèle laroque
et oui oh la la
comment
on ne trouvait pas de goûter mais
physiquement ça vous ferait peut-être
plaisir c'est le seul truc j'ai réussi à
table et n'as pas ton des plus grands
noms mais bien à la hauteur du talent de
mariage
je suis désolé mais je vais la garder
dessus une veste peinte par jamel
debbouze up allait se classe elle l'a
une baisse de 20 par jamel debbouze qui
devait tu devais être ridicule à
l'antenne je sais pas question
d'attendre ce qu'elle en pense on en dit
on au direct à tout ce qui sera dit on
les as tu dirais ça c'est bien voilà la
télévision
les indices et les anéantir et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu